>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: Hello.
>> SPEAKER 1: Hello friends.
Hi.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: That's
the Library of Congress.
>> SPEAKER 1: Welcomes boys and
girls, ladies and gentlemen.
Welcome to the grand opening
at the Young Readers' Center.
[ Applause ]
>> CARLA HAYDEN: So, we might have
some more excitement, we have Batman
in the house we have Heidi, we have
all kind, we have Harry Potter,
there we go witches having fun,
because this is an exciting time.
We're live from the Library of
Congress right in Washington DC
in the Jefferson Building.
And we're in the Young
Readers' Center.
But what's so exciting is that
we're here on a Saturday morning.
This is the first time that the
Young Readers' Center of the Library
of Congress, and we've
got some people coming.
So, while we're here we're going
to have more people coming.
The phone's ringing.
I mean this is just exciting, okay?
This is just, we got a real live
author here that wrote a book.
We've got teenagers with their
outfits on, we're just rolling.
So, first time every that this
Young Reader's Center has been open
on Saturday.
So, we've got some
special things to do.
We are also live streaming.
I think that's what it's called,
live streaming to four cities.
And we practiced saying hello to
you guys in these four cities.
So, we're going to say hello to
the young people in Richmond,
Library North Main Branch
in Columbia, South Carolina.
Hey Richmond.
[ Applause ]
And the Orange County
Library Chickasaw Branch
in Orlando, Florida.
Hey Orange County [applause].
And the Princeton Public
Library in Princeton, New Jersey.
Hey Princeton [applause].
And last, but certainly not least,
the Saint Agnes Library Branch
on Amsterdam Avenue, in
New York City [applause].
All right, now, this was so
exciting they had to write
down everything I'm supposed to say.
So, if you are watching on
YouTube, and we are on YouTube,
on YouTube you can Tweet us
your questions using the hashtag
celebrate young reader.
Everybody got that?
Hashtag celebrate young reader.
Well, throughout the
day, all day on Saturday,
I mean this is something, Saturday.
We are going to have
all kinds of things.
And some of you have already been
doing things, making bookmarks.
And look we've got shoes
that are lighting up.
Put your foot up [laughter].
I might have to take
a nap after this.
This is just too much.
I know we might all
have to take a nap.
We're going to have snacks,
it's going to be good.
So, it's just good.
I mentioned though that to start
it off, we have a special guest.
An award-winning Author, Ms. Meg.
Medina.
[ Applause ]
And she's going to talk
about her new book that's
in English and Spanish.
And she's going to take questions.
So, I'm going to throw it over
to Ms. Meg, take it away Meg.
>> MEG MEDINA: Well, good
morning everybody [foreign word].
A couple of things before we
start reading, because we have to,
we're in the library so we're going
to have a story time
all of us together.
But first I want to say how
exciting it is to be at the Library
of Congress in a room specially
for young people with our brand new
and wonderful librarian of
Congress, Dr. Carla Hayden,
so I want to give her a huge.
[ Applause ]
And thank you for making the
library a really welcoming place
for young people.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: Now, those
people in the back shh.
All those adults back there, shh.
>> MEG MEDINA: They're
always a problem the adults.
I want to give a shout out,
because as some of you know my work
and I write for kids who
are 4, and 5, and 6, and 7.
But I also write for kids who are
8, and 9, and 10, and 11, and 12,
and 13, 14, 15, 16, and 17.
So, just this month a new book
came out called "Flying Lessons
and Other Stories" and this is for
kids who are in elementary school.
And it's a collection of stories
written by authors from all kinds
of backgrounds, and I
have two special friends
who came to the library.
And they're ready to tell
you all about this book.
One is Ellen Oh, who is the
editor, and Ellen is going to stand
up back there [applause].
So, please make sure you talk to
Ellen about the fantastic stories
in this collection by Jackie
Woodson and Kwame Alexander,
and Tim Federle, and all
other fascinating people.
And next to Ellen is
my other good friend,
Lamar Giles, standing up back there.
And he will be the editor of
the next book in that series.
Instead of middle grade stories,
it's going to be YA stories,
meaning stories for teens.
So, be on the lookout for "Flying
Lessons and Other Stories."
But we have business to attend
to this morning my friends.
Raise your hand if you
have a grandma or grandpa.
Raise your hand, if you
Or a [foreign word].
Yes. I did too.
And here's what I remember
about that experience,
that when I was five, do I
have anybody who's five here?
Do this is you are five, okay.
When I was five, my [foreign
word] came to live with us.
MY [foreign word] and my
[foreign word] they came from Cuba
and I hadn't met them before.
And I was very worried about them.
So, all these years
later when I grew up,
I decided you know what I'm going
to write a story about a girl
and her grandmother,
her [foreign word].
And they're going to have
a very special problem
that my grandmother
and I sort of had.
And that's this, that [foreign
word] spoke Spanish really well
and really quickly.
And it sounded to me
like this [babbling].
And I spoke English really well
and really quickly and it sounded
to her like this [babbling].
And when we met each
other and we wanted
to be friends we were
like, oh, uh-oh.
So, I wrote a book.
Now here's the deal about this book.
Right now I speak Spanish
and English.
So, I'm going to read
the book both ways.
And on this screen you're going to
have the pictures and you're going
to have the words in English and in
my lap, I have the book in Espanol.
So, we're going to
have to be patient,
which is a really good quality
when we're talking about people
who speak other languages.
So, when I'm reading in English,
the folks who are live streaming
watching the live stream,
listening to this, wanting
to hear it in Spanish,
they're going to wait
really patiently.
And when I finish English
and I go to Spanish,
you're going to wait
really patiently and look
at the pictures drawn by
my friend Angela Dominguez.
Are you ready?
Yes? Okay.
I need my clicker, which is way
over there and I need a person
with long arms, [foreign
word] thank you.
Okay. So, this will be a trick,
I've never done this this way,
so remember the word here,
patience [foreign word].
So, oh, what happened.
I'm at the end, I'm going backward.
Hold on I'm going all the
way backward, backward,
backward, backward, backward.
There we go.
"Mango, Abuela, and
Me by Meg Medina.
That's me.
She comes to us in winter, leaving
behind her sunny house that rested
between two snaking rivers.
Her old place was too much for just
one mommy tells me, as we make room
in my dresser for her clothes.
And too far away for
us to help poppy adds.
Abuela belongs with us now
Mia, but I still feel shy
when I meet this faraway
grandmother.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
Sorry. Ping, pong, boom.
Poppy unfolds Abuela's bed and
slides it right next to mine.
You get to know each other he says.
But when I show Abuela my new book,
she can't unlock the English words,
we can only look at the pictures
and watch Edmund race on his wheels.
But then just before
we turn out the light,
she pulls out two things
tucked inside the satin pocked
of her suitcase.
A feather, [foreign word] from
a wild parrot that roosted
in her mango trees and a
snapshot [foreign word]
of a young man with poppy's smile.
[Foreign Word] she
says climbing into bed,
snuggled in my pajamas I
smell flowers in her hair,
sugar and cinnamon baked into
her skin, and that night I dream
of a red bird circling the sky.
Ping, pong, boom.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
The rest of the winter while
mommy and poppy are at work,
Abuela waits for me to
get home from school.
Then we bundle up in thick socks
and handmade sweaters to walk
to the park and toss
bread to the sparrows.
My Espanol is not good enough
to tell her the things
that Abuela should know.
Like how I am the very best in art.
And how I can run as
fast as the boys.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
And her English is too [foreign
word] to tell me the stories
about all I want to know
about Abuela and those rivers
that ran right outside their door.
With our mouths as empty
as our breadbaskets,
we walk back home and watch TV.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
Abuela and I cannot understand
each other, I whispered to mommy.
Oh, things will get better mommy
says, remember how it was with Kim?
Kim is my very best
friend at school.
When she was new, our whole class
had to help teach her English words.
Now, Ms. Wilson sometimes
has to say,
please be quiet girls,
others are working.
Sound familiar?
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
After school, the next day while
Abuela and I are making meat pies
for our snack, I pretend
that I am Ms. Wilson.
Dough, I say pointing to the ball.
Abuela says, dough?
[Foreign word] and rolls it flat.
[Foreign Word] I say.
She drops a spoon full of
meat in place, [foreign word].
[Foreign word] I say, meat.
[Foreign word] raisin.
[Foreign word], oil.
And that page I'm going to skip
in Espanol, because you get it.
Then, I remember the word cards we
taped in our classroom to help Kim.
So, while Abuela fries our [foreign
word] I put up word cards too
until everything is
covered, even Edmund.
Soon, we are playing [foreign
word] and say all around the house.
But that night, oy, she still
calls my pillow a pallow,
and she says Edmund is a gangster.
We'll keep practicing I whisper.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
But the next day, I cannot
practice with Abuela after all.
Edmund has run out of his
favorite seed, so mommy and I have
to ride the bus downtown
to buy more.
Sometimes there are kittens
in the pet shop window,
but when we arrive something
even better is behind the glass.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
Look. I say, the window has
become a jungle filled with birds,
and right in the middle is a parrot
staring at us with black bean eyes.
I press my nose to
the glass thinking
of the feather Abuela gave me.
Let's buy him, I tell mommy.
But Mia you already have Edmund.
Mommy says.
Oh, no it's not for me.
I say, it's for Abuela.
Like the parrot that
lived in her mango trees.
He can keep her company
when I'm in school.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
When we bring him home to Abuela,
she says, [foreign word] a parrot
and we name him Mango,
because his wings are green
and orange and gold like the fruit.
During the day, Abuela teaches
him to give beaky kisses
and to bob his head when she
sings [foreign word] to him.
[Foreign word] Mango Abuela
says opening the cage door
when I get home from school.
Good afternoon.
I say and give him a seed.
And soon Mango calls to me,
even before we open the
cage [foreign word] he says
when I open the door.
Oh, good afternoon.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
Abuela, Mango and I
practice new words every day.
My Espanol gets faster and faster,
and Abuela and Mango learn the days
of the week, the months of the
year, the names of the coins.
How did he learn all that poppy asks
when we show him all
that Mango can do.
Abuela winks at me and gives Mango
a piece of banana, peal and all.
Practice, she says.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
Before long, Abuela asks me
how to say harder things too
so that she can talk to
the neighbors that stop by.
Has the mailman come today?
It is chili today.
Can I get you some
cookies and lemonade?
Soon when friends stop by to
see Mango's latest tricks,
they can understand
everything Abuela says,
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
Has the mailman come.
It is chili today, can I get
you some cookies and lemonade?
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
But, best of all, now when Abuela
and I are lying next to each other
in our beds, our mouths
are full of things to day.
I tell her about my [foreign word]
and show her my best [foreign word]
of Mango and Abuela
reads my favorite book
with only a little help.
And she tells me new stories
about Abuelo who could dive
for river stones on a single breath
and weave a roof out of palms.
I draw pictures for her.
She misses their old house she
says, but now only a little bit.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
Mango listens to use from his
perch until my eyes grow heavy.
[Foreign words] I say, Abuela
kisses me good night, Mia.
[Foreign Word] Good
night, Mango calls.
And soon we fall asleep.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
The end.
[ Applause ]
>> CARLA HAYDEN: Do you think
it would be nice for the library
to have a mango right here?
>> MEG MEDINA: Yes.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: I like Edmund.
>> MEG MEDINA: I like
Edmund on that wheel too,
that poor little gangster hamster.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: Well, we're going
to have, do you have any questions?
We have questions from our friends
all over the country, so we're going
to start asking, anybody
have a question,
like was Edmund really a
hamster or a gangster [laughter]?
A gangster hamster.
>> MEG MEDINA: If anybody's
had a hamster,
they know that hamsters
can be gangsters.
Yes, they get out of cages, they
do all kinds of crazy things.
And they try to steel all
the seeds and stuff them
in their cheeks like that big.
>> SPEAKER 1: How about we
start you guys off with one
of our friends who
are tuning in today.
We'll start off with
Columbia, South Carolina.
We have Jayla, age
5, asking Meg Medina,
was it hard to learn
English and Spanish?
>> MEG MEDINA: Oh, hi Jayla.
Thank you for asking that question.
It wasn't for me because when
I was little my mother spoke
to me at home in Spanish.
And I spent all day in
school speaking English.
And so, I learned from the
time that I was very little
that speaking two languages
was just having more words.
And so, the only confusing part
that happens still sometimes now,
is that there are somethings that
you can really say well in English,
or really say well in Spanish,
that doesn't have a good
translation in the other language.
Like for example, I'll
give you this one.
In Spanish, and Cubans in particular
if they say boy that's crazy, right?
They say [foreign words].
Which means you throw
the mango really far.
Can you imagine if I
went around saying,
boy you got to throw the
mango really far on that one?
My American friends would say,
I think she's loco in the cocoa.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: That's
the point though.
>> MEG MEDINA: So, thank you.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: Heidi
had a question.
>> SPEAKER 2: What
was your question?
>> CARLA HAYDEN: Ask your question.
>> SPEAKER 3: Yeah.
Why did they get mango?
>> MEG MEDINA: Why did they
get Mango in the story?
I think she wanted to make
her grandma feel better
about missing her house.
Sometimes when we move to a new
place we miss our old place.
Raise your hand if
you've ever had to move
from one place to another, yeah.
That can be scary.
And you want to remember
the good things
of the place that you came from.
So, I think Mango was a helper
to help them talk to each other,
but he was also a helper to
make Abuela feel at home.
And that's something we can do
when we have new people come
to our classroom, new people
come to our neighborhoods,
new people come to our family.
We want to make them
feel loved and safe.
>> SPEAKER 1: We have a question
from another one of our friends.
This friend is named Emily,
she's nine and she has a question
from Orange County Library
System, Orlando, Florida.
And this one is for Dr. Hayden.
What does a librarian do?
>> CARLA HAYDEN: Oh boy,
[ Laughter ]
>> MEG MEDINA: Sit back folks.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: Well, I'm
so glad you asked Emily.
And I was born in Florida,
Tallahassee, so hey.
So, I know about moving.
And what a librarian gets to
do is have fund like today
when you can do things and show
people what fun reading is,
and meet authors like Miss Medina.
And you get to pick books
for other people to read.
And I get to have excuses to read.
It is one of the best
things you can do I think.
But being a librarian is all about
reading and letting people find
out about things and helping
them find out about things.
So, it's a pretty cool job.
>> MEG MEDINA: Do you
know if I wasn't a writer
and I also was not a
dancer in my next life,
which I would like
to come back dancing,
I would love to be a librarian,
because my librarian even now,
maybe this happens to you.
Do you go to the library sometimes
and you don't know what to read.
I go to the expert.
And I say what's new, what's good?
And they always give
me the best advice.
And the other thing I love
about librarians is that it's
like they're opening a
magic door for me to walk
through and experience a story.
So, I'm so glad you're a
librarian and that there are
so many good librarians out there.
Thank you, librarians.
[ Applause ]
>> CARLA HAYDEN: Yeah,
librarians are wizards of words.
So, we have Harry Potter
and it is just a joy.
Now, we have another question too.
>> SPEAKER 1: We have
questions streaming
in from our friends
who are watching today.
This one is from Maddie, 6 years
old and she's in Princeton.
And this is a question for both of
you, Maddie says I read every day.
Do you?
>> CARLA HAYDEN: Yes.
>> MEG MEDINA: I'm
never not reading.
Never not reading.
I love it, love it.
In fact, when I don't read, I don't
feel well does that happen to you?
>> CARLA HAYDEN: Right.
When I'm very, very tired,
I can tell I'm really,
really tired because I can't read
and that's when I need to take
that nap, I need to do
something because I love to read,
well can I share with you my
favorite place to read, in bed.
>> MEG MEDINA: Me too.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: It's
the best thing.
And sometimes I wake up and
there are books and magazines
and stuff in the bed with me.
And it's so cool.
>> MEG MEDINA: Do you know, I had
a neighbor once, her name was Liz
and she had three little kids and
one of her daughters, I remember,
that young woman is in her
twenties now, but as a little girl,
she could only go to sleep if
her bed was filled with books.
And she read until the moment
her eyes dropped and she'd wake
up in the morning touching those
books, I think her name was Kate,
if I'm not mistaken, and
I've always remembered that.
I read in bed too.
It's such a comfort.
And I like going to sleep
with my imagination.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: And sometimes
it's better than a movie,
because the movie's in your head and
you can make up whatever you want.
You can make the pictures
yourself sometimes.
So, it's really kind of cool.
Another question.
Oh, right here.
Or, you could just say stuff too.
>> SPEAKER 4: Why did you want
to speak Spanish in the book?
>> MEG MEDINA: Why did she
want to learn to speak Spanish?
She wanted to be able
to talk to her grandma.
>> SPEAKER 4: I mean why did you
decide to do the book in Spanish.
>> MEG MEDINA: Oh why, a
more discerning question.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: That's right.
She got the story.
>> MEG MEDINA: Thank you now.
Thank you for that clarification.
Well, miss, thank you very much.
That's a really good question
and here's why, because I think
that there are a lot of kids in the
US who speak English and Spanish.
And lots of families where some of
the people speak English and some
of the people speak Spanish.
And I like to give them books where,
no matter what language
they're most comfortable in,
they can come together
around the story.
The hard part, when I'm
reading is waiting, right.
It's hard to be patient.
And that's true when we're
reading books in two formats.
It's true when someone is new to
English and they're trying to talk
to you and you're listening really
carefully and trying to be patient.
But they're trying to tell you
their story, even if it's a sentence
that they want to tell you.
So, for me I like including
everybody that I can in the story.
Good answer?
>> SPEAKER 1: We have
a question over here.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: And we need more
stories in other languages too.
>> SPEAKER 5: All right go
ahead and ask your question.
>> SPEAKER 6: Why did they give
the hamster to her, to the grandma.
>> MEG MEDINA: Say that
question one more time, why?
>> SPEAKER 6: Did they give
the hamster to the grandma?
>> MEG MEDINA: Why did she
have a hamster in the story?
Why was there?
>> SPEAKER 5: No.
>> MEG MEDINA: Oh,
I'm not doing well
with like interpreting questions.
Okay I'm paying attention now.
>> SPEAKER 6: Why did they give
the hamster to the grandma?
>> MEG MEDINA: Oh, well
she already had Edmund.
She already owned him.
Edmund was her pet.
And so, she wanted to
add Mango the parrot.
She didn't add Edmund.
Edmund was already hers.
Do you have a pet?
>> SPEAKER 6: Yeah.
>> MEG MEDINA: What do you have?
>> SPEAKER 6: A dog.
>> MEG MEDINA: Me too.
What's your dog's name?
>> SPEAKER 6: Onyx.
>> MEG MEDINA: Onyx.
My dog's name is Hugo and
he's a big black shaggy dog.
What does your dog look like?
>> SPEAKER 6: He's black
and he has light brown feet.
>> MEG MEDINA: He must be beautiful.
And I like that name, Onyx.
Other questions.
Oh, a wizard.
>> SPEAKER 7: Well, just like
her dog, her dog's name is Onyx.
My dog's name is Donyx.
>> SPEAKER 1: And we have
one question over here.
>> SPEAKER 8: Why did
you make two books?
>> MEG MEDINA: Why did I?
I think because I can't not do it.
When I don't write I
don't feel very well.
So, I love to write stories.
I like to, when I was little
I liked to hear stories.
And now as an adult, I
still like to hear stories,
I still like to read stories, but
now I like to write them also.
Do you like to write stories?
Yes. So, you know what
happens to people like you?
You become people like me, or you
become people like Dr. Hayden,
like book lovers we become
librarians, we become authors.
If we like to draw the pictures
we could become illustrators,
the person who draws stories.
So, there's lot of stuff
for book loving people.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: Batman
has a question.
>> MEG MEDINA: Oh, Batman, yes.
>> SPEAKER 9: Why we get
the grandma in the story?
>> MEG MEDINA: Why did I write
a story with a grandma in it?
I like grandmas.
I think grandmas, and
grandpas, and aunts, and uncles.
I think family is really important.
So, I like to write stories where
we get to see people's families.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: And there are
all types of families, too.
That's what I've learned, too.
There's all kinds of families and it
doesn't matter and its really cool
to have all types of
people in the family.
I had a rabbit, Auto
was in the family,
but everybody can be in a family.
>> SPEAKER 1: We have
another question.
Yes, this is a question from
Zeke who is 7 years old.
And he is Orange County Library
System, Orlando, Florida.
This is for Dr. Hayden.
How many books are
there in your library?
>> CARLA HAYDEN: I know
that one [laughter].
There are, and think about this,
and that's why we're so excited
that you're going to be
here more and more and more.
Thirty-two million books.
Just books.
Then there are, I even, it's
so much to even say how much,
a hundred million other
things, comic books, games,
all types of photos, everything.
That's a lot of stuff, isn't it?
>> MEG MEDINA: Thank goodness
you have it because you know
when I write books, I come to
the library to do research.
So, I came to this library,
to the Library of Congress
when I was writing me,
I have novel called
"Burn Baby Burn" for teenagers.
And I came right across
the street and spent a lot
of time doing research here.
And the other thing that I
don't know that they can see,
but maybe they could do a
virtual tour on the website.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: We're
working on that.
>> MEG MEDINA: Is how beautiful
the Library of Congress is.
It's two buildings.
We're in the Jefferson Building,
and there's the Madison building.
But this building where we are.
There's three buildings?
>> CARLA HAYDEN: Three
buildings right around here.
There's another one.
You've got to go to that
one too, the Adams Building.
>> MEG MEDINA: Thank goodness
I have tutor on the side.
There are three, but I
knew there were two, but.
The Jefferson Building you
just shouldn't miss it.
And you should go up into
the rotunda and just look
at how beautiful a monument
it is to books and knowing
and thinking and learning.
And that really matters.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: And the cool
thing is that it's your library.
This is everybody's library.
So, Florida, New Jersey, New York.
This is your library too.
And I'm glad you said that about
the virtual tour, because very soon,
you will be able to take a virtual
tour of all three buildings.
And there's even another
one in Virginia [laughter].
All three buildings.
You'll be able to look and it's 3-D.
and walk about, so
we're working on that.
So, wherever you are you
can tour the buildings.
>> MEG MEDINA: Yeah.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: Great.
Oh, now there's some.
Look we must be having too much fun
because now the adults
want to ask questions.
>> MEG MEDINA: Yeah, they want
to get in on the action now.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: Okay we'll
let him, we'll him here you go.
He's going to ask a question/
>> SPEAKER 10: Dr. Hayden could
you tell us what was President's
Jefferson's involvement
in establishing the
Library of Congress?
>> CARLA HAYDEN: Wow.
Now you could tell that
was an adult question.
>> MEG MEDINA: And I'm
so glad it's yours.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: And I
happen to know that one too.
Because what this gentleman wanted
to know is why is this even called,
the building that we're in now
is the Thomas Jefferson Building
and he said what was,
how was Thomas Jefferson?
He was a president a long time ago.
Very, very important president
because he thought about a lot
of things when the country
was getting started.
And one of the things he said
was, this is a new country.
It was new 1796, way back, he said
you know what a new country needs?
It needs a library.
And he made sure that books form his
library were given to the country
so we could have this
wonderful thing now.
So, thank you for asking that.
And thank you Thomas Jefferson.
We got another one from our?
>> SPEAKER 1: We do this
one is from New York.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: Oh, New York City.
>> SPEAKER 1: New York.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: Amsterdam Avenue.
>> SPEAKER 1: Queens, New York.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: Queens,
that's Jamaica, New York.
>> SPEAKER 1: They actually want to
know if you miss living in Queens,
and also the real question is,
Jessica wants to know
is there a difference
in how you write chapter
books and picture books.
>> MEG MEDINA: Yes.
And I am from Queens,
I'm from Flushing Queens.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: Oh, I
thought you said Jamaica.
>> MEG MEDINA: No, that, you see
there's Queens peeps everywhere.
Flushing Queens is where I'm from.
And there is a difference in
how you write every kind of book
because you have to think
about who's reading the book
and how long the book can be.
How many words that reader has
to be able to unlock your story.
Is somebody going to be reading the
book with them, or are they going
to be reading by themselves.
So, there are all kinds
of things that I think
about that have to do with this.
The first thing I ask myself is
what story do I want to tell.
The second thing is
who am I telling it to.
And then the third thing is
what's the best way to tell
that story to that person.
So, I have to match
those three things up.
Sometimes I make a mistake.
And I try it in one way and I go no,
no it doesn't make sense this way,
it's much better as a novel, or
as a picture book, or whatever.
But those three things in
some way have to line up.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: Wow, that
takes a lot of thought.
>> MEG MEDINA: It does.
It's a brain buster.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: It looks
so wonderful and everything.
Wait a minute is there
a metal on that book?
>> MEG MEDINA: There is a
metal on that book my friend.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: Oh, could you
tell us, whenever you see this kind
of metal on a book, that
means that it won a prize.
So, could you tell
us about the prize?
>> MEG MEDINA: I can and I'm glad I
can and I'm glad I can tell you this
with the question from New York.
Because this book won a prize
called the Pura Balpre Award,
the honor for writing
and for illustration.
And I was not the illustrator,
the illustrator is a wonderful
woman names Angela Dominguez
who is also a writer and writes
and illustrates her own books.
So, find her stuff.
Pura Balpre was a librarian.
She was the first Afro-Latino
librarian in Harlem,
I believe in the twenties.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: Yes, 1920s.
>> MEG MEDINA: Yeah.
And she looked out at her
students and she looked at them,
and she looked at the kids who
were in the pages of the books
in her library, and
said wait a minute.
This doesn't exactly match.
We need more stories and more books
that have all kinds
of people in them.
So, she dedicated her whole
life to diversifying, to create,
getting stories and books
that reflect all people.
And so, when the book comes
out, every year books publish,
there's a committee called the Pura
Balpre Committee and they read,
and read, and read,
and read, and read.
And they're looking for books
that celebrate Latino life
and experience in the United States.
And then they pick a
winner for illustration,
and they pick a winner for writing.
And I'm so proud that this
book got that last year.
Not this year, but last year.
Thank you for asking.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: And I remember when
I was 7 years old in Jamaica Queens,
and there was a little
store front library right
across from my school, PS 96.
And I went in and a librarian
gave me a book called
"Bright April" and
I lived that book.
I loved it so much
I got library fines.
Yes. You know why I loved it?
Because it was about a little girl
who was seven or eight years old.
And she looked just like me.
She was brown, she had
pigtails, she was a brownie.
And I just loved it because I
looked in the book and I saw myself.
And I said, it must be pretty
good if I can see myself.
And it meant a lot to me to
just have that and I hugged
that book, and hugged it.
I think I still have fines.
But I loved that book to this day
because I could see myself
in something I loved.
>> MEG MEDINA: I love that
you're from Jamaica Queens,
I went to PS 22, where did you go?
>> CARLA HAYDEN: PS 96.
Public school is public school.
Public school and in New York that's
what you do PS 96, but that meant
so much to me because I was
already looking at books to find
out about other people and I
loved books and I love reading.
But I never saw myself in a book.
So, it meant a lot.
>> SPEAKER 1: The next one is
going to be the last question.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: Oh, we
have one more question
and then we have, we
have two questions.
Okay three last questions.
>> MEG MEDINA: All right, three
super-fast last questions.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: Okay, here's
the first one right here.
>> SPEAKER 11: When
you're little did you
like to read and write a lot?
>> MEG MEDINA: Yes.
To become an author, yes.
Really to be anything.
It pays to read and write a lot.
And it's also super fun.
So, you really don't mind doing it.
But yes you have to good reader.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: And then
we have another person.
A teenager.
>> SPEAKER 12: So, first
of all good morning.
All right so, like I'm
from Missouri, right?
And I'm an artist, yeah, and I
consider writing to be like art.
So when I'm doing my thing, like a
make music and I paint and stuff,
so like when I'm doing my thing
on an instrument or something,
I feel like it comes best to me like
when I'm a vessel and it just pours
out of me, it's like spontaneous.
So, I want to know like
what's your method of writing
like how do you get the stories out?
>> MEG MEDINA: So, I love the
fact that you have all kinds
of arts at your disposal.
And you're right, there's a whole,
as an artist there's
a whole time period
where it's just coming out of you.
And how that looks for me is
that it will be a sentence
that I write down somewhere.
Or it will be a photograph
that I see somewhere
that I cut out and I hold on to.
When I wrote the book, "Tia Isa
Wants a Car" for a long time,
that sentence just
kept coming up to me.
Tia Isa wants a car.
I have a Tia Isa, she did
buy the first family car.
And for some reason that
sentence kept jamming in my head.
And you probably have
the same thing,
a phrase that you can't get rid
of and then it becomes something.
The important thing is, is that
you follow it, just follow it.
But thank you so much
for your question.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: And before we have.
>> SPEAKER 12: Thanks for
being here, I appreciate it.
>> CARLA HADEN: Isn't this cool to
have people who create and write
and all of that and we're going
to have more and more of this
on Saturdays, let's give a
hand for Saturdays [applause].
Saturdays are good days.
And it's a time when
you can do things.
So, we're going to actually
do something really fun.
We have one more question from our
friends and we're just going to wave
to her before we go because we
have a special ribbon cutting.
We are going to cut the ribbon
to this room to say it's open
on Saturday, come and everything.
We have scissors that are this big.
We have two teenagers
from our advisory board.
We also want you to know
that we want you to come back
and tell us what other
things would you like to see
in this Children's
Center and Youth Center.
So, we're going to be getting
a lot of ideas from people.
We hope that we can have more
authors like Ms. Medina to talk
to you wherever you
are on a regular basis.
That would be good.
So, we have one more question from?
>> SPEAKER 1: This
is from Princeton.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: Princeton,
New Jersey.
>> SPEAKER 1: And this one is
from Marissa, nine years old.
Meg Medina, what is
your next book about?
>> MEG MEDINA: My next book?
My next book the main character's
name is Marcie Suarez and she lives
in Florida with her mother, and
her father, and her brother,
and her grandmother, and her
grandfather, and her [foreign word],
and two really pesky
twins, Lao and Thomas.
And everybody is just
in her affairs.
And she's 12, and she's
going to a new school.
And at the same time, she's
noticing somethings changing
with her friends, changing with her
grandfather, changing with herself.
That's a much as I got.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: So, stay tuned.
Well, thank you MS. Medina.
We just can't thank you enough.
We're going to cut the ribbon
and we are going to look,
I'd like to have our
two helpers come up.
We have, and I mentioned we have
an advisory board here and all
of you are going to be helping us
from the Richard Wright Public
Charter School here in Washington.
An 11th grader, Veronica Payne, and
another 11th grader, Edward Tolson.
Now, kids everywhere,
everywhere we are.
We're going to need your help.
So, who wants to come
and help hold the ribbon?
Come on. You're going
to hold the ribbon.
Okay. Now, we've got all the
cameras and we're going to do this.
And then we're going to count
down, Ms. Medina, okay you got it.
Where are the big scissors?
Have you ever seen
scissors this big?
These are big scissors.
Now, we got to be careful, though.
You know you got to be
careful with scissors anyway.
So, when you have super
big scissors, okay.
So, we are going to have
someone help us cut here.
You want to help?
Okay now watch Batman,
watch it, okay be careful.
>> SPEAKER 1: 5.
>> CARLA HAYDEN: Count
down everybody.
>> SPEAKER 1: 5, 4, 3, 2, 1,
[ Applause ]
>> CARLA HAYDEN: Thank you.
And guess what.
Our 11th graders are
going to say something.
You guys were really good
at this ribbon cutting.
The scissors were good.
Who's going to speak first?
Veronica's going to speak.
>> VERONICA PAYNE:
Good morning everyone.
How are y'all today?
Okay. Well, my name is Veronica.
I attend Richard Wright
Public Charter School.
And I am also a part of
the teen board program here
at the Library of Congress.
[ Applause ]
First, I want to start off with
how great I think this program is.
Ms. Cathy and the other
staff work really hard
to make sure we're
comfortable and engage
in the discussions we
have at each meeting.
If I wasn't already a book lover,
I would be after spending a day
with Ms. Cathy because her
enthusiasm for books is inspiring.
Because of this program, I've met
new authors, read amazing books,
and enjoyed some pretty good snacks.
I've never left our meetings
without learning new things,
whether it be about books or
other students in the program.
That's what I like about
the teen board program.
I'm surrounded by people
that may be unfamiliar
but enjoys books just
as much as I do.
This program is a place where
young people can freely express
themselves, just reading,
writing, and talking about books
without fear of judgment.
That's why I'm very thankful
for the team board program
and everything I've learned
an experienced from it.
[ Applause ]
>> EDWARD TOLSON: I'm 16
years old and I'm a Junior
at Richard Wright Public
Charter School
for Journalism and Media Arts.
The Young Readers' Center Teen
Board has been a great getaway,
where I can read, envelop my
thoughts and express myself
through reading literature.
I've been a part of the Teen Board
of the Young Readers'
Center for two years now.
In my opinion, the Young Readers'
Center just keeps getting better
for me along with the selection
of books that are available.
When I joined the teen
board program,
my first impression was it was
going to be your average book club,
where you write summaries
of books written years ago.
This is because it was being
housed in the Library of Congress,
where lots of old books are housed.
However, that was not the case.
The Young Readers' Center Team
Board itself is multidimensional.
We are exposed to new
books every month.
Distinguished authors
have visited and amazed us
with how they got started writing
and enthusiastic librarians
that forged the way for us to have
great snacks and wonderful books
from various genres for
our reading pleasure.
I continue to enjoy our
teen board monthly meetings
where we discuss our books and hear
about what other students have
read while enjoying the embracing
environment and loving cultural
of the Young Readers' Center.
The Young Readers' Teen
Board is a great program
for young readers everywhere looking
to embrace literature while
cultivating their minds
and expanding their
horizons through reading.
[ Applause ]
>> CARLA HAYDEN: Now, there's a
reason why we wanted you to hear
about the teen advisory board and
how much fun that is, the snacks,
you'll be getting some
snacks yourself.
And we think, and what do you think?
How about a kid board?
Right. The teens are
having all the fun,
we think the kids should
have some too, right?
So, we want you to think about
being part of the new kid board.
Give yourselves a hand, I think
you all have good questions.
You can do it.
And to celebrate that and to
celebrate Ms. Medina being here
and all the cools stuff
because we're going
to really renovate
and fix this place up.
We're going to throw stuff
around, and make a mess.
Yeah, we're just going to make amess
and have a good time
and have refreshments.
So, now somebody, who's going to
tell us how we're going to do this?
Because we're just going to;
okay, are you going to show us?
Okay, we're going to count down
again and thank you for all
of our friends in New Jersey,
and New York on Amsterdam Avenue,
Florida, one more; South Carolina.
Let's say good-bye to
everybody [applause].
Thank you and we hope to see you
soon and come help us make amess.
Come on; 1, 2, 3 yeah.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at low.gov.